President Joe Biden was up in
Connecticut over the weekend for a gun
control Summit at the University of
Hartford where the president focused his
remarks on a prayer for the long life of
a dead English monarch and if you could
see the camera they can see you and it's
the least consequential part of this
whole meeting for you I promise
all right God Save the Queen man
yeah
and then the best part is he he just
points he goes am I supposed to go off
this way am I and I and as he does that
the crowd there they go
God Save the Queen man
on the one hand probably the most
conservative and dignified thing Joe
Biden has ever said a little bit late
didn't didn't totally make sense in the
middle of Connecticut nine months after
Queen Elizabeth died
back I kind of like I know it's better
than a lot of things the guys said even
Joe Biden's professional Spin Doctors
can't make sense of it perhaps Biden
confused New England with old England
perhaps Joe Biden was referring to drag
queens it was a little bit of a pride
month valedictory nah not quite not
quite convincing the only explanation is
the one that we've all known for a long
time which is that Joe Biden
who was never The Brightest Bulb in the
pack
is fading even further
a couple fries short of a Happy Meal few
cans short of a six-pack know what I'm
saying catch my drift the lights are on
but no one's home and we all know it but
the ruling class can't do very much
about it Joe Biden is the incumbent
he's almost certainly the Democrat
nominee for president in 2024. so if the
Democrats want to hang on to power
they're going to have to rig the
election which is exactly what they are
currently doing right now go to
cinch.com use code nulls picture the
perfect Summer Night the warm breeze on
your face as you Lounge in your favorite
chair outside the grill is sizzling with
those juicy delicious burgers the aroma
of the food it's irresistible
now imagine what this perfect summer
night would look like if you went to
turn on the grill and your propane tank
was empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule and requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
you track the order on the Cinch app
from anywhere whether you're grilling
steaks or lighting up the patio heaters
on a chilly night cinch's propane
delivery service ensures that you have
the fuel that you need to make the most
of every moment go online to cinch.com
or download the Cinch app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks with promo
code Knolls cinch.com or download the
Cinch app cynch use promo code Knolls to
get your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks it's a limited time offer you must
live with an essential service area to
redeem it go to cinch.com offer for
details we're now allowed to openly talk
about rigging the election even on
certain big Tech platforms that may have
banned me last week we're back we're
back for now but now you're allowed to
talk about that now that the 2020
election is over and the Democrats got
away with it you're allowed to openly
even on these platforms not just on
daily wire plus where I had previously
been talking about this but but openly
on big Tech you're allowed to say what
we all know which is that the Democrats
rigged the last election by changing all
of the voting rules in the weeks and
months before the election took place
and they changed those rules in a way
that was advantageous to Democrats
and which hurt Republicans so how are
they rigging the election this time not
not just by changing the voting rules in
some cases some of the rules have
changed back but broadly the Democrats
have just kept that Victory widespread
mail-in ballots they've kept the uh
changing of rules such that it even
contradicts the state constitutions as
we see in Pennsylvania uh ballot
harvesting all the rest of it how are
they changing at this time how are they
rigging at this time they're rigging it
by
indicting the chief political rival
and they're indicting him in New York
and they're indicting him on federal
charges in Miami and they're going after
him in all sorts of ways there were
there were civil actions coming up they
are just going to try to Pummel this guy
with the law such that they can either
bury his campaign or literally put him
into prison and and it's not just my
opinion that this is election
interference this is the opinion of most
Americans
even if it were just my opinion I think
that's a good enough reason to you know
take it seriously but according to a
Harvard Harris poll most people believe
that the Trump indictments constitute
election interference
of registered voter respondents 55
percent say the indictment is
politically motivated versus only 45
percent who find the indictment valid
which is an interesting way of phrasing
the question because the indictment
could be valid and politically motivated
and it could be
not politically motivated but also
invalid not not legally serious but here
you've got a clear majority of people
who say it's politically motivated and a
clear minority of people who say that
it's it's
valid similarly 56 percent of the
participants categorize the indictment
as interference by the Department of
Justice in the 2024 elections only 44
see this as a fair application of the
law so Americans know what's up it's not
just the Republicans it's not just the
conservatives even Democrats a lot of
Democrats fair-minded Democrats
understand this is Joe Biden wielding
his political power to rig the game
against the leader of the political
opposition which is something that we
have never seen anywhere near this scale
in American history deeply corrupt a
major shift in our political order even
the Democrats are admitting it
so you know that you can rely on Mitt
Romney to defend it you know you know
when something is so clear it's so
obviously favoring the liberal
establishment you know that you can rely
on Liberal Republicans such as Mitt
Romney to defend the uniparty swampy
establishment strategy
I'm angry the country is going to go
through tumult as a result of one thing
president Trump didn't turn over
military documents but he was asked to
do so
all he had to do was hand him in
I'm sure his counsel told him hand the
documents in particularly when the
subpoena came but for some reason he
decided not to he held on to them why
that's the question why is the country
going to have to go through all this
angst and tumult why do you just turn
the documents in
I am angry I'm angry I I don't even want
to do my Romney impression because it's
not good enough and I end up just
sounding like Reagan and I don't want to
compare Mitt Romney to Ronald Reagan he
says I am angry I'm angry at Trump
I'm angry at the Republicans I'm angry
at the conservatives you can always rely
on Mitt Romney and the Republicans like
Mitt Romney to punch right
They Don't Really punch left
the LM is burning the country down Mitt
Romney is going to be out there marching
with BLM
Donald Trump is selectively prosecuted
for an alleged crime that many of his
predecessors potentially all of his
predecessors but at the very least many
of his predecessors
and his successor Joe Biden all
committed
but it's Trump's fault
of course this is preposterous
if if
virtually every modern president has
committed this one crime
and Donald Trump is the only one who's
prosecuted for it then the thing that
changed here is not the presidents or
what the presidents are doing the thing
that changed is the doj the thing that
changed is the prosecutors the the
person who deserves the blame is the top
prosecutor in the country and his boss
Joe Biden
Romney won't say that because the debate
that we're seeing in our country
increasingly is not between Republican
and Democrat the debate we're seeing our
country is increasingly not between
leftist and conservative the debate in
our country is as Patrick Deneen writes
in his new quite good book uh regime
change this conservative writer Patrick
Denine says that the the big divide now
is between the many and the few the
people and what we call the unit party
the elite Democrats
and the elite Republicans joining
together this is how you're getting talk
of say
a Donald Trump
may be picking
Democrat Bobby Kennedy Jr as his running
mate how honor what how on Earth does
Trump the I guess Conservative
Republican share a significant amount of
voters people who admire
Bobby Kennedy that's so Str how is that
because that old political divide is
breaking down to something a little bit
more basic and a little bit more
populous boy wasn't that a great clip
here on YouTube It Was Here on YouTube
isn't that great and make sure you
subscribe to the Michael Knowles Show
YouTube channel well you still can and
we'll see you next time